hi i'm sabra klein i'm a professor of
molecular microbiology and immunology at
the johns hopkins bloomberg school of
public health where i am also
co-director of the center for women's
health sex and gender research today i
will be presenting a discussion to you
entitled sex matters for respiratory
viral pathogenesis and responses to
vaccines
i thought we could begin with
ensuring we all have an understanding of
what it means to say that sex is a
biological variable
so as a biological variable this is
referring to the biological differences
between males and females based on sex
chromosome complement
reproductive tissues and the hormones
that are secreted
in females
in particular female mammals there are
two x chromosomes
in male mammals there is an x and a y
chromosome
on the y chromosome is a gene
abbreviated sry which encodes for test
is determining factor
in the presence of this hormonal factor
and others
the bipotential gonad develops into a
testis that
primarily post-puberty will begin
secreting high concentrations of
androgens including testosterone and
dihydrotestosterone
in the absence of a y chromosome the sry
gene and testis determining factor the
bi-potential gonad develops into an
ovary that post-puberty
will secrete high concentrations of
estrogens and progesterone
now i'm treating this as though sex is
binary and we know that disorders of
sexual development do in fact occur and
that sex can occur along a continuum
unfortunately to date we understand very
little about the immunological
consequences
of intersex or other disorders of sexual
development so for our discussion today
i am going to stick to this binary
treatment of sex but please know that
myself and others are very interested in
exploring
the diverse range of sexes
now these hormones can only have their
biological effects by binding to
specific
receptors that are located in the
intracellular space of cells that
possess these receptors
and it turns out that many immune cells
including macrophages dendritic cells
neutrophils natural killer cells and
lymphocytes like t cells and b cells all
contain receptors
for sex steroid hormones
generally speaking in the presence of
estrogens and progesterone and hence
activation of their respective receptors
we see an increase in immune related
activity
in the presence of high concentrations
of androgens
or great activity of the androgen
receptors we typically see a decrease in
immune related responses
as a result when it comes to viral
diseases including respiratory viral
diseases
in the presence of estrogen and
progesterone as well as two x
chromosomes
defining females we tend to find that
females clear virus quite readily
but the downside of this greater
activity of immune cells is that there
is a greater risk of immune related
pathologies
in males again as defined as having an x
and a y chromosome as well as high
concentrations of androgens binding to
androgen receptors on immune cells
this can in turn contribute to a male
bias
in reduced vaccine
efficacy or reduced vaccine-induced
immunity
as well as persistence of viral
infections
when it comes to viral infectious
diseases including those that occur
outside of our respiratory tract sex
differences have been observed
i'm showing you these differences in the
context of a host damage response so to
orient you to this graph we have host
damage ranging from a low degree of
damage to a high degree of damage on our
y-axis
and immune responses ranging from weak
to strong
the disease response curve is located in
black and we can have a high degree of
disease in the event that we have a weak
immune response which can contribute to
a high degree of host tissue damage
possibly due to virus replication
and if we follow this curve all the way
around
we see that we can also have a high
degree of
disease or tissue host tissue damage
in the event that an immune response is
too strong
what i've listed here are some of the
viruses for which we know that either
increased virus replication
or host mediated immunopathology
contribute to disease outcomes
the stippled line that i've drawn in the
middle
just separates this out
and and provides us with a testable
hypothesis
for viral infections in which
tissue damage is being caused by an
inability to control virus replication
i predict there will be a male bias in
those diseases and today i will use sars
kobe 2 as our example
in contrast for viral diseases in which
immune mediated pathology contributes to
a worse disease outcome
i would hypothesize that we would see a
female bias in disease outcomes and i
will use influenza viruses as my example
well let's begin with influenza viruses
i've worked with these viruses for well
over a decade and just recently i had a
wonderful opportunity to work with a
group of investigators at the national
institutes of health
where they were conducting
human
h1n1 influenza virus challenges
and utilizing several of their their
trials we looked to see if we could see
sex differences in outcomes from
influenza virus challenge of what i
would refer to as young adult
people
so as you can see we had 164
participants in this study
people were challenged with influenza
again an h1n1 strain of influenza and
were followed for up to eight weeks post
challenge several outcome measures were
measured and they were measured
separately for males and females and the
differences were compared
bolded are those outcomes for which
significant sex differences were
observed
it turned out that while males and
females did not show differences in the
hemagglutination inhibition antibody
titers
so that's inhibition of the viral
protein abbreviated ha which is very
important for virus entry
sex differences again were not observed
but when we looked at
na or neuraminidase inhibition
and neuraminidase is another viral
antigen that's very important for
release or the exit of virus from
infected cells we found that males
actually had greater in
n a inhibitory immune responses as
compared with their female counterparts
both four and eight weeks after
challenge
females had
a greater presence of symptoms so they
were presenting
with symptoms for a longer duration of
time
and had a greater number of total
symptoms reported
females appeared to have greater disease
and one hypothesis that we have is that
the greater antibody response against n
a in males may be contributing to better
outcomes a hypothesis that we still need
to test
one of the ways that we can test
hypotheses that are generated from human
studies is to use animal models which
allow us to get a bit more invasive and
and to really explore mechanisms
mediating sex differences
so using adult c57 black six mice that
we can infect with diverse influenza
viruses in this case much like the
previous slide we've worked with h1n1
influenza viruses
and when we infect male and female
mice with influenza a viruses what we
typically find is that females
stereotypically pink tend to get sicker
than males
we can't ask our mice what symptoms they
possess so one of the ways in which we
can determine sickness is by measuring
their body mass because much like humans
when mice get sick they tend to huddle
in a corner and not eat as much and they
do lose weight
as you can see females lose more weight
than males and it takes them longer to
recover than it does males
when we look at viral titers in the
lungs at several time points after
infection what we consistently have
found is that among naive animals for
whom this is their first and only
infection we typically don't see sex
differences in the ability to control
virus replication
but by 14 days post-infection so after
virus has been cleared
if we look back at our body mass graph
you can see that females have still not
recovered in terms of in terms of their
body mass
and if you look at the graph to the far
right
where it's labeled on the y-axis dfco
that's diffusion capacity or exchange of
co2 and o2 across the lungs the stipple
baseline pulmonary function for males
and females for which there is no sex
difference and what we find is out 14
days after inoculation
males have returned back to baseline
pulmonary function whereas females are
still
below the normal range for pulmonary
function so even in the absence of virus
females still have not returned to
to complete respiratory health
on the bottom left if we look at
inflammation
histologically and and we quantify this
by a scoring system
we find that females 14 days after
inoculation again long after virus has
been cleared
have more inflammation noted in their
lungs
if we measure cytokines in the pulmonary
tissue including tnf alpha and ccl2
both of which are
inflammatory mediators of disease
following influenza virus infection
and we look at this within the first
week after inoculation with an h1n1
influenza virus we find that females
have greater induction of these as well
as other pro-inflammatory mediators as
compared with males
so it is not that males are not engaging
in an immune response they are
but when we see an almost 100-fold
increase in the presence of certain
proteins in the lungs this suggests to
us that this response may be excessive
and contributing to tissue damage and
worse outcomes in females
to highlight the important
immunosuppressive or immunoregulatory
activities of androgens in the context
of inflammation and influenza virus
infection
we have looked at the effects that
androgens play and specifically androgen
receptor signaling and dampening
influence excuse me and dampening
inflammation during influenza virus
infection
so again using c57 black six in this
case male mice who are adults so
typically eight to ten weeks at the time
of infection
and again measuring body mass is a
general indicator of clinical disease
what we find among males is that go
natalie intact males so males who have
their testes
do not lose as much body weight mass as
males who've had their testes removed
the removal of the testes is referred to
as gonedectomy and that's abbreviated
gdx on these slides
gonadectomized males get much sicker
than go natalie intact males
on the far left graph
if we replace
testosterone in these males who've been
gonna ectomize
we find that they respond in a similar
way to h1n1 influenza virus infection in
which they experience a less severe
outcome
in the middle graphic in the middle top
graphic
if we not only treat gonadectomized
males with testosterone
but we co-administer a drug called
flutamide which is an androgen receptor
antagonist
this significantly imp reduces
body mass and in other words makes h1n1
influenza infection disease severity
worse so if we block androgen receptors
we block the protective effects of
testosterone
well one thing i haven't told you yet is
that our sex steroids being steroids
they all derive from cholesterol
and estradiol actually is derived from
testosterone through
the an enzymatic conversion
by an enzyme called aromatase
we can also work with what we refer to
as a
non-aromatizable androgen so an androgen
that cannot be converted to estradiol to
then subsequently bind to an estrogen
receptor
and it's abbreviated in the far right
graphic dht and that stands for
dihydrotestosterone
and so what we did is we go nut
ectomized males we replaced testosterone
in some animals dihydrotestosterone in
other animals and then still other
goodness
animals received a placebo
whether we treated animals with
dihydrotestosterone
or
testosterone we saw an improved outcome
this was not due to differences in virus
replication but instead as seen in the
lower panels
was due to a dampening
of both inflammatory monocytes as well
as virus-specific t cells particularly
after virus had been cleared from the
lungs
well this greater immunity in females
while is detrimental in terms of
inflammation and inflammation mediated
disease
when females recover from influenza
virus infection
what we find is that the
adaptive immune responses are typically
greater for females as compared with
males so when we measure things like
serum igg
or
we measure iga specific to our h1n1
virus and bronchoalveolar lavage fluid
so in the respiratory tract we find that
females now the open bars
have greater
adaptive immune responses than their
male counterparts
we also find that in the lungs females
have more antibodies secreting cells as
cells secreting in this case iga
as well as a greater number or frequency
of cd4 positive t cells as well as cd8
positive t cells both memory cells as
well as
resident memory cells which is quite
exciting when we think about what that
might do in response to a secondary
challenge
so this got us thinking about vaccines
and if females who recover from
infection have greater adaptive immune
responses maybe females who are
vaccinated would also mount greater
adaptive immune responses to test this
we use a prime boost strategy for
vaccination with a monovalent h1n1
vaccine in male and female mice
we then wait 28 or 35 days after the the
primary vaccination and find that
females do in fact have greater titres
of igg as well as neutralizing antibody
which is shown in the middle panel not
only is the quantity of antibody greater
for females than males but the quality
of that antibody is greater females have
greater ability
in of their antibody as compared with
males
not only do females have greater avidity
but another marker of quality is class
switching and class switching to
igg2c and c57 black six mice is
indicative of an antiviral antibody
response
of which females have greater titers
than males
well one of the important mediators of
class switching of igg 2
igg2c and away from igg1
involves an x-linked gene
called toll-like receptor 7 a gene we
often think of in the context of innate
immunity but that can be equally
important in b cell mediated or antibody
mediated immunity
if we isolate b cells
from vaccinated male and female mice and
measure relative gene expression we find
that b cells from females have more tlr7
as compared to b cells for males we do
not see a similar sex difference in the
closely related tlr8 gene
again tlr7 is located on the x
chromosome
in many cases this shouldn't matter
because there should be random x
inactivation
of one copy of each gene on the x
chromosome to control for the dosage
effect of having two x chromosomes
now there are many ways in which
x-linked genes can escape x inactivation
and roughly 15
of human genes encoded on the x
chromosome escape x inactivation
including tolic receptor 7
in our mice what we observed was an
epigenetic mechanism mediating greater
expression of tlr-7 and b-cells from
vaccinated females as compared with
males
in which we showed greater dna
methylation in the promoter of tlr7
following a vaccination in male as
compared with females and so this
reduced dna methylation may be
contributing to the greater expression
of tlr7 in b cells from females as
compared with males
well these sex differences in immunity
to vaccine contribute to greater
protection following virus challenge
something that we're thinking about a
lot now in the context of sars cov2
so in our mice when we challenge
vaccinated males to close circles and
females the open circles
we find that females are better able to
control and clear
virus from their lungs as compared with
their vaccinated male counterparts
and again we can't ask animals how
they're feeling so we can look at things
like changes in body mass
with the stippled line indicating the
baseline body mass prior to challenge
females don't change much from baseline
they really don't get sick whereas
vaccinated males are in fact getting
sick and experiencing some level of
disease
we know this is mediated by toe-like
receptor seven because when we knock out
toe like receptor seven and i will say
this is a complete knockout not specific
to b cells something we still need to do
we eliminate the sex difference in
antibody responses including
neutralizing antibody responses as
pictured here
as well as the sex difference in the
ability to control virus replication
within vaccinated animals following
challenge
the last point i want to make before
moving on to sarsko v2 is that not only
are x-linked genes important but
estrogens can be very important too by
causing elevated immunity in females
we've shown this association in humans
and we can show the cause effect in mice
so if we jump to the bottom panel for
the sake of time what we find is that
females who are vaccinated have greater
antibody responses as compared with
their male counterparts
if we go nut ectomize males and females
take away the testes and males take away
the ovaries and females we eliminate the
sex difference and if we replace
testosterone exogenously in
gonodectomized males and if we replace
estradiol exogenously in females who
have been gone ectomize we reinstate the
sex difference so we know that these
hormones play fundamental roles possibly
in modulating some of the genes and b
cells including x-linked genes like
toll-like receptor seven
so greater immunity in females of
reproductive ages contribute to both
worse outcome from influenza as well as
better outcomes from vaccination
i'd now like to change gears and talk
briefly about sars cov2 a virus a
respiratory virus that needs no
introduction at this stage but what may
need an introduction is that there are
sex differences in the severity of
covid19
and sex-disaggregated data from around
the world consistently show that while
the number of cases especially prior to
rollout of vaccines
were consistently similar between males
and females hospital hospitalization as
well as icu admissions and even death
following confirmed cases
are consistently greater for males as
compared with females
to show you another way of looking at
these data we took these data from
various countries during the first wave
of the covid19 pandemic
and we've rank ordered them here
and what we're looking at are data from
38 countries blue stereotypically male
pink stereotypically female and what we
find when we look at case fatality rates
they were consistently greater for males
as compared with females
for 10 countries these data were not
just broken down between male and female
but they were also broken down by age
ranges
and what we find is that at diverse age
ranges i should say adult age ranges so
among individuals 20 years of age and
older within each age group
males are significantly more likely to
die than females
but i think it is also very important to
make the point that among females very
consistent with what we see in males
there is an age-related increase in
severity or an age-related increase in
the likelihood of dying from sars cov2
and again this is among unvaccinated
individuals
when we used electronic health records
from johns hopkins we found something
very similar when we looked at the
proportion of individuals who were
tested
and looked at those that tested positive
for sars cov2 among those that have been
tested
and we did this separately for males and
females across diverse age groups what
we found was that among individuals 18
to 49 years of age all the way to 65 to
74 years of age a greater percentage of
males were testing positive this
reversed at both the younger ages as
well as the older ages and others have
reported this reversal of the sex
difference as well at these age groups
however when we look among those who
tested positive those that had severe
enough disease to be admitted into the
hospital we found that significantly
more males were being admitted into
johns hopkins hospitals among
individuals ranging from 18 years of age
upward to 64 years of age
in our paper which is currently in press
at open forum infectious diseases we
report
that in all of our modeling it was
inflammatory markers that were the
greatest predictor of worse outcomes
from
sars kovi to infection and severe cobit
19 disease
pictured here are two of the
inflammatory mediators that we measured
il-6 and c-reactive protein
and what i want to show you is that in
most cases if a sex difference is
reported it's reported collapsed across
all ages where we do in fact find
greater inflammatory responses among
males as compared with females within 48
hours of admission
but when we take a closer look it's
really the younger aged individuals that
are driving this difference we really
see the most pronounced male bias in
these inflammatory mediators among
individuals 18 to 64 years of age with
this really equaling out at these later
ages
where we think this could be important
is that elevated il-6 is but one
indicator used for determination of
receipt of monoclonal antibodies
that can block the il-6 receptor
and while
more males do in fact
qualify for administration of this
monoclonal antibody treatment than do
females when we look at proportions a
significantly greater proportion
of males who qualified are actually
receiving these treatments at johns
hopkins so this highlights to us that
not only could there be some sex
associated differences but gender
associated differences as well
not only do males have greater
inflammatory responses early after
infection but once they've convalesced
or recovered from covid19 infection we
find that males have greater antibody
responses
to sars cov2 antigens as well as
neutralizing antibodies against the
virus than do females it's consistently
been shown that individuals with more
severe disease so those who are
hospitalized tend to have greater
antibody responses older aged
individuals
also have greater antibody responses and
we are now showing that male sex is yet
another predictor of greater antibody
responses however more recently we're
starting to observe that the durability
of that antibody may not be as good for
males as compared with females
we've also done work to develop an
animal model to allow us to get a bit
more mechanistic in how we explore sex
differences in sars kobe 2 pathogenesis
so using male golden syrian hamsters we
have observed that consistent with
humans
males get sicker than females so again
we're looking at body mass changes
following infection and here we find
that males are actually losing more of
their body mass and taking
about a week longer to fully recover
than their female counterparts
when we look using ct scans at the lungs
of these animals as in panel b we do
find what looks like the development of
pneumonia with those ground glass
opacities
we can also use unbiased ways
or or modeling
in order to identify affected areas of
the lung and create these
three-dimensional models to then
quantify the proportion of affected lung
relative to total lung and when we graph
that as in panel d
we find that males have significantly
greater a significantly greater
percentage of affected lung
as compared with females so they are
experiencing more pulmonary disease than
our female hamsters
we can look using histology as well as
flow cytometry we can see greater
infiltration of immune cells
particularly inflammatory myeloid cells
in the lungs of infected male as
compared with female hamsters and that's
what's shown in the bottom um in the
bottom graph but interestingly we do
find that females have more lymphocytes
than males
while we don't see sex differences in
virus replications whether we measure
virus titers or viral rna copies in the
lungs
much like with the greater numbers of
lymphocytes seen in the lungs of female
as compared with male hamsters we find
that antibody responses both in the
blood so when we look at igg
to total sars cov2 inactivated virus
or in the right if we look at at
recognition of the spike receptor
binding domain
again in the wild type as well as in
several variant viruses females the open
symbols have greater antibody responses
than their male counterparts in the
closed symbols
if we look locally in the lungs for iga
we find that iga recognizing the spike
receptor binding domain is greater for
females as compared with males and we're
seeing that the kinetics of this
antibody is remaining higher for females
out as late as 28 days
infection
so whether we use epidemiological
country level data electronic health
records clinical patient samples or
animal models biological effects affects
responses and outcomes from sars kovi to
infection
i'm grateful for all of the members of
my lab and my wonderful collaborators at
johns hopkins as well as the funding
that we've received for this research
thank you